- Are you doing okay?
- No one knew I was police until today.
Police!
- You're a pig living here with us?
(dramatic music)
- Had you ever seen the victim before?
- No.
Get back! Get back!
(explosion)
- Wallander, don't skip the counseling.
- I should have been there, man.
- I'm not cut out for this.
- I want Wallander on the case.
He lives here.
He has connections here.
- It's time to ask yourself
how much you want to be a detective.
- I think I've got something.
Hugo's murder was carefully choreographed
to look a certain way,
to escalate the immigration conflict.
(crowd roars)
- You're brave, coming back.
- This came from the outside.
Help me find who it was.
- The Hugo Lundgren grenade
flipped a switch on a case
that intelligence had
been building for months.
- He's been smuggling
weapons into Malmo for years.
- Going after him is what's
known as a career ender.
(camera shutter clicking)
- Do you know something about him?
- All that money and privilege,
it messes with your head.
- What are you hiding?
- This gentleman was just leaving.
(explosion)
- Cases like this will take
everything that you have.
- This job's full of tough choices.
- Why didn't you tell me the truth?
- I wanted to protect you.
(man grunting)
I swear to you, I'm going
to find the man responsible.
You will see justice.
- Welcome to the job.